Екс-радник українського президента-втікача Віктора Януковича
Екс-глава передвиборного штабу Дональда Трампа
Екс-політтехнолог як американських президентів, так і закордонних диктаторів
Усі ці регалії з префіксом "екс"
стосуються Пола Манафорта
31 липня проти нього розпочався
судовий процес у США
Що варто знати про нього
та його махінації українцям?
Пол Манафорт - відомий лобіст та політтехнолог
З червня по серпень 2016
очолював передвиборний штаб Дональда Трампа
З 2005 по 2014 - працював
на Віктора Януковича та Партію регіонів
Сам він полюбляє вихвалятися своєю
співпрацею з Джеральдом Фордом
Рональдом Рейганом та двома Джорджами Бушами
Не полюбляє згадувати про плідну роботу
з двома кривавими диктаторами XX століття
президентом Філіппін Фердинандом Маркосом
і президентом африканського Заїру Мобуту Секо
Через це за Манафортом закріпився імідж
"відбілювача" найгірших диктаторів
і корупціонерів світу
У жовтні 2017 року проти Манафорта
висунули звинувачення в тому,
що він протягом кількох років
лобіював інтереси екс-президента України Віктора Януковича і Партії регіонів
але не був зареєстрований в США
в якості "іноземного агента"
Крім того, його звинувачують
у фінансових злочинах
ухилянні від сплати податків,
дачі неправдивих свідчень
приховуванні інформації
про рахунки в іноземних банках
та відмивання коштів в офшорах
у період роботи на Януковича
Ці факти з'ясувалися під час розслідування втручання Росії в американські вибори
яке вже 14 місяців проводить
спеціальний прокурор США Роберт Мюллер
Манафорта як досвідченого американського політтехнолога
нібито запросили в Україну в 2005 році
близькі до Партії регіонів олігархи
з метою реабілітувати в очах українців
Віктора Януковича
чий імідж значно постраждав після поразки на виборах 2004
виграних Віктором Ющенком
Компанія, очолювана Манафортом,
у період з 2012 по 2014 роки
отримала понад 17 мільйонів доларів
з так званої чорної каси Партії регіонів
Згідно з розслідуванням американських журналістів
Манафорт дуже глибоко проник в українську політичну систему
і мав у кожному українському міністерстві
своїх людей
Крім того, Манафорт буцімто перебував у дуже близьких стосунках з Януковичем
Вони часто грали в теніс і разом вчащали до лазні
Манафорт фігурує у розслідуванні ФБР
про ймовірну змову
між представниками російської влади
та команди Трампа
напередодні останніх президентських
виборів у США
У червні 2016 Манафорт був присутній
на зустрічі функціонерів з оточення Трампа з громадянами Росії
які нібито мали у своєму розпорядженні
компрометуючі матеріали на кандидатку від Демократичної партії Гілларі Клінтон
Наприкінці липняторік ФБР обшукало будинок Манафорта у пошуках відповідних доказів
Відомо про фінансові та особисті зв'язки Манафорта
з російським бізнесменом Олегом Дерипаскою
з близького оточення президента Росії Володимира Путіна
Утім, на цьому судовому засіданні поки не йтиметься
про можливу змову Манафорта з Кремлем
Через скандал довкола роботи на Януковича та регіоналів два роки тому
Манафорт уже поплатився посадою глави передвиборного штабу Трампа
Якщо буде доведено його провину за всіма
12 епізодами звинувачення
Манафорту загрожує до 80 років позбавлення волі
Розгляд справи Манафорта в суді
може тривати три тижні
У суді заслухають свідчення 35 свідків